on dire honte et assidus au travail
c'est ce qui ressort lorsque l'on voit
sara lee à s'entraîner il faut dire que
la jeune athlète baigne dans le milieu
depuis l'enfance
un papa instructeur en art martial une
maman pratiquant le pilates et
encadrants au club impossible d'échapper
à l'appel des tatamis c'est maintenant
dans mon sens qui c'est qui avec une
passion aujourd'hui alors je fais du
sport tous les jours j'en fais la
semaine je travaille mon physique en
faisant du cardio je travaille aussi mes
muscles profonds la respiration et ma
mobilité articulaire avec de pilates
avec ma maman et je travaille aussi j'ai
fait 2 du tram de mach 1 et doubina mme
le samedi
krav maga boxe thaï vovinam viet vo dao
des disciplines affiliés à la fédération
de karaté qu'elle pratique
indifféremment à raison de deux heures
par jour six jours sur sept
le tout couplé à une hygiène de vie et
sans oublier une scolarité des plus
sérieuses de quoi ravir la maman de
cette jeune fille
pourtant réservé mais déterminé ça
l'aide à à s'épanouir
simplement je pense que c'est un bon
moyen pour elle de s'exprimer
elle est
elle est vraiment très à l'aise dans
avec les arts martiaux c'est ça fait
parti balad sa vie alors je vais vous
présenter l'aspect technique du vovinam
viet vo dao et le cul m donc oui alors
c'est l'harmonie entre la force et la
souplesse et en l'occurrence dans fait
que menacer le combat entre les tigres
et les bras c'est c'est vraiment un bon
mélange qui fait que c'est c'est bien
équilibré comme scrutin c'est vraiment
la souplesse et la et la tonicité en
même temps c'est le commun entre le
tigre et le gravier et le type qui
représente la l'agressivité et le dragon
qui est très rare rien qui quand ils
nous révèlent qui est très très peu agi
sur ces sacs on avoue j'ai voulu
présenter chaque année en fait j'essaie
de trouver une amélioration en plus pour
la pâte différente des autres et
toujours ressortir meilleure et une
volonté de perfection sans doute aussi
la force de sarah lisa hubert